- [Gavin] Hello there, I'm Gav.
Welcome to this Slow Mo Guys video.
Now, a Taser being fired
is a highly requested,
that's me waving like an
idiot, highly requested video,
but could never get a hold of
one, so I flew to Scottsdale
in Arizona to Taser HQ
to fire some tasers.
This is the cartridge we're
using, it's for the X26 model.
It's a one-shot cartridge.
And we're gonna be using the V25-11,
which is an extremely fast camera,
because Tasers are extremely fast.
- I'll give you a countdown.
- [Gavin] Okay.
- Three, two, one!
- This was recorded at
1000 frames a second,
and as you can see, still way too fast.
So the V25-11 will shoot
28,500 frames a second in HD.
As you can see, the
penetration of the prongs
is pretty solid.
You want to aim sort of
to split the belt line,
that's where they usually
aim, so one above,
one bellow the belt.
So here's a close-up shot
at 28,500 frames a second
of a Taser being deployed.
And now we're gonna get a front-on shot
of the taser being fired.
- [Man] Three, two, one!
So you're probably wondering a this point,
what's up with the confetti?
These are actually known as the aphids.
It's a good way of tracking
which Taser has been deployed,
who fired it, because each
tiny piece of confetti
has the serial number of
the cartridge that fired it.
Very clever, 'cause you
could never pick them all up.
So Dan's not here today, but luckily,
we've got someone else called Dan.
- Fill-in Dan.
- [Gavin] What do you do for a living?
- I play with these cameras a lot.
- [Gavin] And somehow you've
been roped into getting...
- Yep.
- Exposed with a taser
in a Slow Mo Guys video.
- Apparently they feel like,
y'know, I need some payback
for bringing cameras
to these guys at Taser.
- [Man] Okay, Dan, I want you to relax
in five, four, three, two, one.
- Feels like it's never gonna end!
- Good job, man.
- [Gavin] That was five seconds!
- Felt like a long freakin' five seconds.
- [Gavin] If I speed
up this shot slightly,
you can see that, from the
point of impact, his muscles
contract from right to
left across the shoulders.
Look at that.
Dan, thoughts?
Would you do that again?
- Would I do it again?
- [Gavin] Yeah, if you had to.
- You'd owe me a lot of
money if I did that again.
Someone would be paying some heavy price.
- [Gavin] Ah, that is fully in there.
Do you feel it in you right now?
- I don't really feel the probes.
I feel like, y'know, it still feels like
my muscles are locked up
is what it feels like.
- [Gavin] How's the stomach contents?
Did it all remain where it was?
- [Dan] Yeah, it stays in.
I have not wet my pants.
Life is good.
- [Gavin] Was the noise involuntary?
- That was just comin' out,
I couldn't stop that from comin' out.
I think that was more of my body just...
I think that was more of
just my body convulsing
and pushing the--
- [Gavin] It was pretty manly, though.
- Did it sound pretty manly?
- Yeah, it was like--
- Kinda brave-hearted?
- [Gavin] It wasn't like,
- Oh man!
Look at that ripple going
through the back, jeez!
- [Gavin] So we're keeping the trend alive
of torturing people named Dan.
- If Dan's not here, I guess
a second Dan's always willing
to step up to the plate.
- [Gavin] I hope you enjoyed that video.
Thanks to Taser for letting
me come to film at their HQ.
You can buy a shirt if you want.
And this is a pretty gross shot
of the prong being pulled out.
They're barbed so they
don't bounce out on impact,
so to get 'em out, you need
to give 'em a nice little tug.
Speaking of Tasers, there is
a Taser in the super awesome
upcoming movie Lazer Team.
I'm in it, it comes out in Winter.
Here's some of the trailer,
thanks for watching.
- Why the hell are we Lazer Team, anyway?
- Because I have a laser.
- Yeah, but the rest of us don't!
- Right, you're the team part!
- Nobody cares about your stupid name!
- The helmet heightens
all mental functions
and other visual enhancements.
- Guys!
- The hell is your problem?
- Turn it off, turn it off,
oh god, I wish I was dead!